All of us know the feeling of being stuck. Maybe you're stuck in a job that feels unfulfilling or in a relationship that's making you unhappy. Maybe you're stuck because you want to finish the novel you're working on or learn to speak another language or turn your hobby into a business, but you just can't seem to make it happen no matter how many attempts you try. So is getting stuck just an inevitable part of life, are there things you can do to set yourself up for getting stuck less often? often. How do you know when it's time to quit versus push ahead? And when you do feel stuck, what practical tips can you take to get past the mental, emotional, and other hurdles standing in your way? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
我们所有人都体验过陷入困境的感觉。也许你陷在了一份毫无成就感的工作中，或者一段让你痛苦的感情里。也许你陷在困境中，是因为你想完成正在写的长篇小说、学会说一门外语，或者把爱好变成一门生意，但无论你尝试了多少次，似乎都无法实现。那么，陷入困境只是生活不可避免的一部分吗？有没有什么方法可以让你减少陷入困境的频率？你如何知道什么时候该放弃，什么时候该坚持？当你真的感到困境时，有哪些实用的建议可以帮你跨越阻挡在前方的心理、情感和其他障碍？欢迎收听“心理学漫谈”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，主要探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是吉姆·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
My guest today is Dr. Adam Alter, a professor of marketing at New York University Stern School of Business and an affiliate faculty member in the NYU Psychology Department. He is a social psychologist with a particular interest in how subtle cues in the environment can affect human cognition and behavior. He's the author of three books, including the New York Times bestseller, Irresistible, The Rise of Addictive Technology and the Business of Keeping Us Hooked, which is about the perils of technology addiction. More recently, he has been studying how people and organizations get stuck and how they can get unstuck. His newest book published in May is called Anatomy of a Breakthrough, How to Get Unstuck when it Matters Most. Dr. Alter has also
我今天的嘉宾是亚当·奥尔特（Adam Alter）博士，他是纽约大学斯特恩商学院的市场营销学教授，也是纽约大学心理学系的附属教员。他是一名社会心理学家，对环境中的微小暗示如何影响人类的认知和行为有着浓厚的兴趣。他是三本书的作者，其中包括《纽约时报》畅销书《欲罢不能：成瘾性技术如何俘获我们的心》（Irresistible: The Rise of Addictive Technology and the Business of Keeping Us Hooked），该书讲述了技术成瘾的危害。最近，他一直在研究个人和组织是如何陷入困境以及如何摆脱困境的。他于今年5月出版的新书名为《突破的剖析：如何在最关键时摆脱困境》（Anatomy of a Breakthrough: How to Get Unstuck when it Matters Most）。奥尔特博士还
written for The New York Times, The New Yorker and The Washington Post, among other publications, and has consulted with dozens of companies and organizations around the world. Dr. Alter, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me, Kim. I gave a few examples of different kinds of stuck just a moment ago, being stuck in work in a relationship or in some kind of a creative endeavor. Now, when you think about being stuck, what's the common thread that ties all of these experiences together? I'm interested in particular kinds of stuckness. I'm especially interested in protracted or chronic stuckness. So these are occasions where people feel stuck for sometimes months, sometimes.
为《纽约时报》、《纽约客》和《华盛顿邮报》等出版物撰稿，并为全球数十家公司和组织提供过咨询。奥尔特博士，非常感谢你今天能来。非常感谢邀请我，吉姆。刚才我举了一些不同困境的例子，比如陷入工作、感情或某种创作努力中。现在，当你想到“被困住”时，贯穿所有这些经历的共同线索是什么？我特别关注某种特定类型的困境。我尤其对长期或慢性的困境感兴趣。也就是人们有时会陷入困境数月，甚至
times years, sometimes even decades, or for sometimes, in some cases, their entire lives. So that's what I'm interested in. But I'm also specifically interested in cases where we have some agency. You know, during the early days of the pandemic in 2020, a lot of us couldn't travel. We couldn't do a lot of the things we wanted to do. We were therefore stuck. That wasn't as psychologically interesting to me as a case where we do we do, we do have the power to act. There is something we can do. There aren't government regulations preventing us from doing a certain thing we want to be able to do. And it turns out the vast majority of these occasions of stuckness where people feel they'd like to be in a different situation that often goes on for a long time, most of those cases
数年，有时甚至是数十年，甚至在某些情况下，是一生。这就是我感兴趣的内容。但我也特别关注我们拥有自主权的那些情况。你知道，在2020年大流行刚开始的时候，我们很多人无法旅行。我们无法做很多我们想做的事情。因此我们被困住了。这对我来说，其心理学吸引力不如我们确实有行动能力的情况那么大。有些事情是我们能做的。并没有政府法规阻止我们去做我们想做的事。事实证明，绝大多数这种人们觉得希望改变现状、且这种情况往往持续很长时间的困境，其中大多数情况
we do have some agency over. And so I'm very interested in this book and in general in my research in trying to figure out how we can get unstuck from those situations that tend to plague us for long periods of time. How common is it to feel stuck? I know you've done some surveys to study this. Does getting stuck happen to everyone, at least occasionally? Yes, absolutely. Does it happen more to some people than others? I haven't really looked at individual differences in how often people are stuck, but I've been very interested in how common stuckness is in general.
我们其实都是有一定自主权的。因此，在这本书中以及我总体的研究中，我都非常感兴趣去弄清楚，我们如何才能从那些长期困扰我们的情况中摆脱出来。感到被困住有多普遍？我知道你做过一些调查来研究这个问题。陷入困境是每个人都会遇到的事吗，至少偶尔会遇到？是的，绝对会的。有些人比其他人更容易遇到这种情况吗？我没有真正研究过人们陷入困境频率的个体差异，但我一直对困境普遍存在于多少人当中很感兴趣。
One of the surveys I've been running for several years now has looked at people around the world and asked them a simple question once I define what it is to be stuck, whether there's any area of their lives where they feel stuck. And what's fascinating to me is that the vast majority, I'd say over 90% of them within 10, 15 seconds, start typing a response. And so they're very quick to be able to draw to mind these occasions or instances or areas in which they feel stuck, which suggests that they're quite prominent, they're top of mind.
我几年来一直在进行的一项调查，一直在观察世界各地的人们，一旦我定义了什么是陷入困境，就会问他们一个简单的问题：在他们的生活中是否有任何领域让他们感到困境。最让我着迷的是，绝大多数人，我想说超过90%的人，在10到15秒内就开始打字回复了。所以他们能够非常迅速地在脑海中浮现出这些他们感到被困住的场合、实例或领域，这表明它们非常显著，是他们最关心的事。
They're a big part of what it is to be alive. And so I think of stuckness as ubiquitous. You talk in the book about how people are more likely to get stuck in the middle of a project rather than at the beginning or at the end. Why is that? Yeah, this is some interesting research that looks at goal pursuit and the relationship between goal pursuit and motivation. And what it basically suggests is that at the beginning of a task, you're energized,
它们是生存状态的重要组成部分。因此，我认为困境是无处不在的。你在书中提到，人们在项目进行到中间阶段时，比在开始或结束时更容易陷入困境。为什么会这样？是的，这是一项有趣的研究，它着眼于目标追求以及目标追求与动机之间的关系。它基本上表明，在任务开始时，你充满了活力，
you're usually interested in what you're doing, you bring a lot of good resources to bear on the task. You can imagine any long task, any protracted goal where at the beginning, the fact that you're even starting it usually means that you have a little bit of wind behind your sales. And so that pushes you ahead. At the end of the task, as you can see the finish line, either metaphorical, or literally in some cases, you get another burst of energy because you're sort of drawn
通常对你正在做的事情很感兴趣，你会为任务投入大量优质资源。你可以想象任何长期的任务、任何长期的目标，在开始时，你甚至开始做这件事的事实通常意味着你的顺风顺水。这会推动你前进。在任务结束时，当你看到终点线时，无论是隐喻的，还是在某些情况下字面意义上的终点线，你都会获得另一股爆发的能量，因为你某种程度上被吸引了
almost magnetically to that finish line. But for protracted goals, I liken it a bit to sailing across the ocean between North America and Europe, that you're spending a huge period of time in the middle there between, say, New York and Southampton where you're unable to measure progress. If there is progress, and there may well be progress, it's very, very hard to get a sense of that progress because there are no real signposts or markers in the middle of the ocean. And often in long protracted goals, especially in the middle of those goals, you don't have the same sense of progress, and that can be demotivating. And so there tends to be this quite predictable lull in motivation during the middle part of long protracted goals. And that's not just true of humans.
几乎像磁铁一样被吸引到那个终点线。但是对于长期的目标，我把它比作跨越大西洋航行在北美和欧洲之间，你花很长时间在中间，比如在纽约和南安普顿之间，你无法衡量进展。如果有进展，而且很可能有进展，要感知这种进展是非常非常困难的，因为大洋中间没有真正的路标或标记。通常在长期持久的目标中，特别是在这些目标的中段，你没有那种进展感，这会削弱你的动力。因此，在长期持久目标的中间阶段，往往会出现这种相当可预测的动力低谷。这不仅适用于人类。
It's true of lower order animals as well, but it's certainly very prominent in human behavior. So is one of the tricks to pace yourself? I mean, is that something that can help people not get stuck in the middle of something if they know that they're going to chunk the job down into discrete pieces. Yeah, so part of it is pacing yourself. There's a really interesting phenomenon known as teleo anticipation, which is literally the anticipation of the end. And so what we're supposed to do with protracted goals is to sort of work out either explicitly or implicitly at the beginning of that process, how much energy will I need in total and how should I best apportion that energy across the course of the goal. But that's a really difficult
对于较低等的动物也是如此，但这在人类行为中肯定非常显著。那么，其中一个诀窍是调整自己的节奏吗？我的意思是，如果人们知道自己要把工作拆解成离散的片段，这能帮助他们不在事情做到一半时卡壳吗？是的，部分原因确实是调整节奏。有一个非常有趣的现象叫做“目的期盼”（teleo anticipation），字面意思就是对终点的期盼。因此，对于长期的目标，我们应该做的是，在那个过程开始时，无论是明确地还是含蓄地计算出，我总共需要多少能量，以及我应该如何在整个目标过程中最好地分配这些能量。但这真的是一个困难的
problem and there's often a lot of uncertainty. So what you've described briefly there is another alternative, which is instead of just thinking of the goal as one big goal, you break it down or bracket it more narrowly into sub-goals. And the beauty of that is that instead of thinking of it as one long goal with a very big middle, if you make those chunks small enough, you sort of lose the middle, you eradicate the middle. And so then you have a start, you have a finish, you have a start, you have a finish, and you repeat that process. If you think about writing a book, for example, it's maybe 100,000 words, which is overwhelming. There's a big middle there. But if you think of it instead as, say, you know, 100 periods of writing a thousand words each, the middle in each of
问题，而且往往有很多不确定性。所以你刚才简单描述的是另一种选择，那就是与其把目标看作一个大目标，不如把它拆分或更狭义地划分为子目标。这样做的好处是，与其把它看作一个中间很长、很困难的长目标，如果你把这些块切得足够小，你某种程度上就失去了中间部分，消除了中间部分。这样一来，你就有了一个起点，一个终点，一个起点，一个终点，然后你重复这个过程。比方说，如果你考虑写一本书，它可能有10万字，这让人望而生畏。中间有一个很大的部分。但如果你把它想象成，比如说，100个每个写1000字的时期，每一个
those thousand word chunks is much smaller. And so you tend not to have such a pronounced lull. You also talk in the book about what you call the creative cliff. What do you mean by that term? Yeah, so it's actually, it's not the creative cliff so much as the creative cliff illusion. And it's an illusion that people have that we believe that we become less creative over time when we're trying to think of creative solutions to a problem. So an example of this might be something like there's a new soft drink company and you're working at a company and your job is to come up with good slogans for this new soft drink company. If I said to you, do you think your best ideas will come in the first 10 slogans you come up with
那些1000字的块中间的部分要小得多。因此你往往不会有那么明显的低谷。你在书中还谈到了你所说的“创意悬崖”。你这个词是什么意思？是的，其实，与其说是创意悬崖，不如说是“创意悬崖错觉”。这是一种人们常有的错觉，我们相信，当我们试图为问题寻找创造性解决方案时，随着时间的推移，我们的创造力会下降。一个例子可能是这样的：假设有一家新的软饮料公司，你在一家公司工作，你的工作是为这家新软饮料公司想出好的口号。如果我对你说，你觉得你最好的创意会出现在你想出的前10个口号中呢，
or in the next set of 10 between 11 and 20? And the vast majority of people say, well, the stuff that comes easily to me to, tends to come early. It's going to be harder as I go along. And I generally associate ease with skill, with fluency, with ability. And so just as with learning a language, the more fluent I am with the language, the easier it'll come to me. And so I assume the same about creativity. What turns out to be true, though, is the reverse, which is that it's when things start getting hard, that your ideas become more creative. Instead of there being a cliff over which your creativity tumbles, you sort of lift off, you lift off from the ground at the point where things start to get
还是在第11到20个之间的第二组中？绝大多数人会说，嗯，那些对我来说轻而易举就想到的东西，往往在早期就出现了。随着我继续进行，事情会变得越来越困难。而且我通常把容易与技能、流利度、能力联系起来。因此，就像学习一门语言一样，我对语言越流利，它对我来说就越容易。所以我对创造力也做出同样的假设。然而，事实证明情况恰恰相反，当事情开始变得困难时，你的创意才会变得更有创意。与其说存在一个让你的创造力跌落的悬崖，不如说你在事情开始变得
hard. And so we have this sort of classic problem in human psychology is misinterpreting the signals around us to suggest that we should either quit or that we've already, our best is behind us. And in this case, explicitly the reverse is true, where we tend to do much better with creative tasks only after they start to become difficult. Is it also common for people to hit plateaus in life? And is a plateau the same as being stuck, or is it just a variant? Or are you just sort of cruising along at one steady level. Yeah, so a plateau is really where the returns that you're getting from a particular strategy stop arriving, or they shrink in size. So this might be, for example, there's a very famous example of this, looking at people who are sedentary and then they get
困难的那个点上“起飞”了，你从地面起飞了。因此，人类心理学中存在这样一个典型问题：我们误解了周围的信号，认为要么我们应该放弃，要么我们最好的时光已经过去。而在这个例子中，事实恰恰相反，往往只有在创意任务开始变得困难之后，我们才会在其中做得更好。人们在生活中遇到瓶颈也很常见吗？瓶颈和陷入困境是一回事，还是只是一种变体？或者你只是在某个稳定的水平上平稳前行？是的，瓶颈其实是指你从特定策略中获得的收益停止增长，或者收益规模缩减。这可能表现为，例如，有一个非常著名的例子，研究那些久坐不动的人，然后他们开始
an exercise regime and then they're tracked for a seven-year period. What you find is that these people tend to make gains for the first 12 to 18 months, but almost universally the same thing that they've been doing that was really useful for 12 to 18 months becomes less useful beyond that. So they need to change what they're doing. The same is true for learning and for memory and memorization techniques that we see a similar situation happening when you're, for example, trying to learn a language that if you keep using the same strategy, it becomes less effective over time. And that's an example of plateau. So it could be that you hit a wall. That's one possibility. That's the sort of extreme version. But the alternative is that just the marginal gains you
进行一项锻炼计划，接着对他们进行为期七年的追踪。你会发现这些人往往在头12到18个月里会有所收获，但几乎无一例外，他们一直在做的那些对前12到18个月非常有用事情，在那之后变得不那么有用了。所以他们需要改变他们正在做的事情。这同样适用于学习、记忆以及记忆技巧，当我们看到类似的情况发生时，比如你试图学习一门语言，如果你一直使用相同的策略，随着时间的推移，它会变得越来越不那么有效。这就是瓶颈的一个例子。所以这可能是你撞墙了。这是一种可能性。那是那种极端的形式。但另一种可能是，随着时间的推移，你从进一步努力中获得的
get from further effort decline over time to the point where you're just not getting quite as much back, whereas formerly the same technique was really beneficial. So that's how I generally think of plateaus. They don't have to be that you stop making progress altogether, but you certainly slow down. Let's talk about some of the advice you offer in the book, because there's quite a lot there, and it's very good. One thing you advise is to talk to other people when you're feeling stuck, especially to people who are unlike yourself. Why is that helpful? Yeah, it's a tremendous resource that humans have that really other animals do not have. We have a tremendous social network to draw upon when we're stuck.
边际收益会下降，直到你获得的收益大不如前，而以前同样的技巧却非常有用。这就是我通常对瓶颈的理解。它们不一定意味着你完全停止了进步，但你肯定放慢了速度。让我们来谈谈你在书中提供的一些建议，因为那里有很多内容，而且非常好。你给出的建议之一是，当你感到困境时，要与其他人交谈，特别是与那些与你不同的人交谈。为什么这很有帮助？是的，这是人类拥有的一项巨大资源，而其他动物真的没有。当我们陷入困境时，我们可以利用一个庞大的社交网络。
And if you speak to people who are like you, who have the same background, perhaps the same expertise, maybe they've trained the same way, maybe they grew up in the same place, maybe they have the same demographic characteristics, you'll find that they will magnify whatever you've been doing. So if you're doing something well, they will probably tell you to keep doing it or they'll help you keep doing it. But if you're stuck, by definition, you might get more entrenched in your stuckness by speaking to people who are like you because they'll magnify that stuckness. The best thing you can do is you can speak to people who are either different from you.
如果你和那些像你一样的人交谈，他们有着相同的背景、也许相同的专业知识、也许他们受过相同的训练、也许他们在同一个地方长大、也许他们有相同的人口统计特征，你会发现他们会放大你一直在做的事情。所以如果你做得好，他们可能会告诉你继续这样做，或者他们会帮助你继续这样做。但如果你陷入困境，根据定义，通过与像你这样的人交谈，你可能会更深地陷入困境，因为他们会放大这种困境。你能做的最好的一件事就是与那些与你不同的人交谈。
The technical term is non-redundant. In other words, there's no overlap. Or you can talk to people who actively push back on your ideas if you're open to that. And the value of that is, instead of having 10 overlapping minds, if you speak to 10 people who all see life a little bit differently, you're getting 10 independent sources of wisdom. And then your job really is just to comb through those 10 different sets of ideas and to figure out what works best for you. And so the idea there, as with much of what I talk about in the book, is that quality and quantity are strongly related. And so if you get more ideas, if you have more people sharing ideas that are distinct, you're more likely to find some good ones.
专业术语叫作“非冗余的”。换句话说，没有重叠。或者，如果你能接受的话，你可以和那些积极反驳你想法的人交谈。这样做的价值在于，与其拥有10个重叠的大脑，如果你与10个对生活有不同看法的人交谈，你就会获得10个独立的智慧源泉。然后你真正的工作只是仔细梳理这10种不同的想法，并找出最适合你的那一种。所以这里的想法，就像我在书中谈到的很多内容一样，是质量和数量密切相关。因此，如果你获得更多的想法，如果你有更多的人分享独特的想法，你就更有可能找到一些好点子。
Another piece of advice that you offer, which seems to apply particularly to being stuck in a creative endeavor, is to take the pressure off yourself to come up with things that are entirely new and unique, and instead to think about recombining ideas. Can you talk about that? Yeah, this is one of the ideas that I came across. I love the arts in general, but I particularly love music. And I've always been really interested in this question that's now become a legal issue in a lot of cases, which is, are people stealing from others? Are artists stealing. their ideas, their songs, their melodies, their chords and so on from other artists who've written music in the past. And when you speak to experts, they'll tell you that almost never
你提供的另一个建议，似乎特别适用于陷入创作困境的人，那就是卸下对自己“必须想出完全崭新且独特的东西”的压力，转而思考如何重组想法。你能谈谈这个吗？是的，这是我偶然发现的想法之一。我总体上很喜欢艺术，但我特别喜欢音乐。我一直对这个问题很感兴趣，这个问题现在在很多情况下已经成为一个法律问题，那就是：人们是在窃取别人的东西吗？艺术家们是否在窃取
does that happen. It's very rare for someone to say, I'm going to rip off this other artist because it's often transparent. It leads them to hot water. It's not a good idea professionally. And so I don't think that happens very often. But I think what does happen is we are constantly borrowing. You use the term recombining, which is a term that I use in the book. We're essentially taking two unoriginal ideas, but putting them together in a way that is original. We're recombining them in a way that's new. So I think true radical novelty is vanishingly rare in creative pursuits. But I think what's much more common and what is often a better thing to strive for,
他们的创意、他们的歌曲、他们的旋律、他们的和弦等等，从过去创作过音乐的其他艺术家那里。当你与专家交谈时，他们会告诉你，这种情况几乎从来没有发生过。很少有人会说：“我要抄袭这个其他艺术家”，因为这通常是一目了然的。这会让他们陷入水深火热之中。从职业角度来看，这不是一个好主意。所以我不认为这种情况经常发生。但我认为确实发生的是我们一直在借用。你用了“重组”这个词，这也是我在书中使用的词。我们本质上是拿两个毫无独创性的想法，但以一种具有独创性的方式将它们组合在一起。我们以一种全新的方式将它们重组。所以我认为，真正激进的新颖性在创意追求中是极其罕见的。但我认为更常见的是，而且通常是更值得追求的目标，
a better aim to strive for is to say, I think what I want to do is find two things that have never been combined in a particular way and combine them in that way and see if that brings me value. What's really interesting to me is, as I was doing research for this book, I wanted to sort of figure out who is the closest to being radically original. And if we traced back far enough, could we find that their originality breaks down at a certain point? One of the examples that comes up very often for people is Bob Dylan. A lot of musicians say Dylan's a genuine, true, radical original. But if you look at Dylan's own words and you look at where his music comes from, even Dylan, as original as he is, was cobbling together a whole lot of different style. and he himself recognized that so much of his work was building on the folk tradition, for example.
一个更值得追求的目标是说：“我想做的是找到两个从未以特定方式结合过的事物，然后以这种方式将它们结合起来，看看这能否带给我价值。”真正让我感兴趣的是，在为这本书做研究时，我想要弄清楚谁最接近彻底的原创。如果我们追溯得足够远，我们能否发现在某个特定的点上，他们的原创性崩溃了？人们经常提到的一个例子是鲍勃·迪伦（Bob Dylan）。许多音乐家说迪伦是一个真正的、彻底的原创。但是如果你看迪伦自己的话，看看他的音乐来自哪里，即使迪伦再怎么原创，他也是将许多不同的风格拼凑在一起，
And so you do this with art, you can do it with filmmaking. It's just very, very rare to find radical originality. And so recombining elements tends to be the better way to go. Did you find any radical originals? No, not really, to be honest. I think if you go back far enough, you do find the lineage of almost every idea in someone else's work. Who invented the wheel or fire? Yeah, I'm sure even before the invention of the wheel, there was someone pushing around something slightly oblong shaped.
他自己也承认他的很多作品都是建立在民俗传统的基础之上的，例如。所以你可以对艺术这样做，你可以对电影制作这样做。要找到激进的原创性真的是非常非常罕见的。因此，重组元素往往是更好的选择。你找到任何激进的原创者了吗？不，说实话，并没有。我想如果你追溯得足够远，你会在别人的作品中找到几乎每一个想法的谱系。是谁发明了轮子或火？是的，我确信甚至在发明轮子之前，就有人在推着某种略呈椭圆形的东西。
Someone who invented the wheel saw that and said, hey, I've got an idea. They may have thought it was original, but it was just an iteration, an evolution rather than a revolution. What other phenomenon that you talk about in the book has to do with pivoting? And you tell some really great stories about people who are engaged in looking for, something. Your job is to, you know, maybe invent a drug and you never get there, but then suddenly you discover that something that you found was radically different, but marketable. Can you talk about some of those examples? Because I think the examples you have throughout the book are really rich and interesting. Thank you. Yeah. I think what happens a lot of the time, if you're looking
发明轮子的人看到了那个并说：“嘿，我有个主意。”他们可能认为这是原创的，但它只是一种迭代，是演变而不是革命。你在书中谈到的另一个现象与转向（pivoting）有关。你讲了一些非常精彩的故事，讲的是那些致力于寻找某种东西的人。你的工作是，你知道，也许发明一种药物，而你从未实现，但随后突然你发现你找到的东西是截然不同的，但具有市场价值。你能谈谈其中一些例子吗？因为我觉得你在整本书中举的例子都非常丰富和有趣。谢谢。是的。我认为很多时候，如果你在寻找
for something, if you're trying to make, say it's a clinical drug that you're making or you're searching for some form of originality or success, whether you're an entrepreneur or an artist, it doesn't really matter what you're doing, is you become very heavily invested in the thing that you're working on. You pour your heart and soul into it. And the golfer Sam Sneed, who is known for having the most beautiful swing of all time, describe the process of swinging the golf club as cradling a bird. You don't want to cradle it so lightly that it flies away, but if you cradle it with too much force, you end up crushing it. And that's kind of how I think the best, most nimble minds think about their ideas, that you don't want to be too flighty. You want to pursue the
某些东西，如果你试图制造，假设是一种临床药物，或者你在寻找某种形式的原创性或成功，无论你是企业家还是艺术家，你做什么其实并不重要，你会对你正在做的事情投入大量的心血。你倾注了你的心血和灵魂。高尔夫球手萨姆·斯尼德（Sam Sneed）以拥有史上最美丽的挥杆动作而闻名，他将挥杆过程描述为“像捧着一只小鸟”。你不想把它捧得太轻以至于它飞走了，但如果你用太大的力气捧它，你最终会把它捏碎。这有点像我认为最好、最灵活的头脑看待他们想法的方式，你不想太轻率。你希望将这个
idea as far as you can, but you need to be open to the possibility that you're wrong or that a slight tweak would improve your returns dramatically. And that's what I kept finding over and over again. A lot of the cases that come up in the history of science are chemists who are exploring new drugs. And there are so many examples of chemists who, for example, accidentally some of the drug they were working with got on their tongues and they tasted this substance and realized that A, it wasn't poisonous because they still were alive. And B, that it was really, really sweet and they didn't realize this. And so a lot of the artificial sweeteners that have then made companies, you know, billions of dollars
想法尽可能地推进，但你需要对以下可能性保持开放：你可能是错的，或者微小的调整会显著提高你的回报。这就是我不断发现的情况。科学史上的许多案例都是化学家在探索新药。有太多的化学家例子，例如，他们使用的某种药物不小心沾到了他们的舌头上，他们尝了尝这种物质，意识到A，它不是毒药，因为他们还活着。B，它真的非常非常甜，而他们之前并没有意识到这一点。因此，许多后来为公司赚了数十亿美元的人造甜味剂，
over the years, come from these kind of accidental discoveries. Now, a lot of people are not receptive to that kind of serendipity. But if you are, if you look for it, if you're always open to the idea, that you might be wrong. There are certain people who are just very good at capitalizing on seizing on these moments. And it's not just about chemistry. It's about art as well, and it's about business. And you see a lot of these cases of people pivoting in ways that ended up being very, very profitable for them. I want to talk for a moment about the idea of writers' block. I would imagine that all of our listeners have heard the term and maybe have experienced it, whether they were
多年来，都来自于这种偶然的发现。现在，许多人对这种偶然性并不接受。但如果你接受，如果你去寻找它，如果你总是对以下想法保持开放：你可能是错的。有些人就是非常擅长利用、抓住这些时刻。这不仅关乎化学。它也关乎艺术，关乎商业。你会看到很多这样的人进行转型（pivot），最终证明对他们来说是非常非常有利可图的。我想花一点时间谈谈“作家阻滞”（writer's block）的概念。我想我们所有的听众都听过这个词，也许也经历过，无论他们是
in college and they had to write a term paper or maybe in their jobs to. today where you have an assignment to produce a big report. Is there really such a thing as writers block or is it just that people can't get started? And what are the techniques that can get you unstuck in that kind of a situation? Yeah, it's so funny because this is a term that I always took for granted. I assumed that it was a concept that was well recognized, that everyone agreed, yes, there was something called riders block or at least some version of it. But it's such a polarizing term because you speak to some writers and they say, oh, I have no idea what you're talking about. That's a ridiculous concept and I just sit down and I write. And they're very firm about that.
在大学里必须写学期论文，还是在今天的工作中，你有一个任务要写一份大报告。真的有“作家阻滞”这回事吗，还是人们只是无法开始？在那种情况下，有什么技巧可以帮你摆脱困境？是的，太有趣了，因为这是一个我一直认为理所当然的词。我以为这是一个广为人知的概念，大家都同意，是的，有某种叫做作家阻滞的东西，或者至少是它的某个版本。但这却是一个极具两极分化的词，因为你跟一些作家交谈，他们会说：“哦，我不知道你在说什么。那是个荒谬的概念，我坐下来就写。”他们对此非常坚定。
And then there are other writers who say, oh yeah, every day is riders block until it's not. And then you have writers who for a decade don't write anything. So it's a fascinating sort of, there's a lot of variance in how we experience it. One of the things I like best though is the attitude of Jeff Tweedy, who is the frontman, the songwriter, the singer for the band, the rock band Wilco, and also himself a writer. He writes a lot of books. and things like that. So he's a Renaissance man who his trade is really creativity. He has to wake up every day and be creative. And like any human being who's open and honest, he says, I don't wake up every day wanting to be creative. My best creative force is not brought to the work that I'm doing
然后还有其他作家会说：“哦，是的，每一天都是作家阻滞，直到它不是为止。”然后还有一些作家十年不写任何东西。所以这是一个迷人的现象，我们在经历它时有很大的差异。不过我最喜欢的态度之一是杰夫·特维迪（Jeff Tweedy）的态度，他是乐队的主唱、词曲作者、摇滚乐队威尔科（Wilco）的歌手，同时他自己也是一个作家。他写了很多书。诸如此类的事情。所以他是一个文艺复兴式的人物，他的职业实际上就是创造力。他必须每天醒来并且具有创造力。像任何一个坦诚开放的人一样，他说：“我不是每天醒来都想具有创造力。我最好的创造力并没有投入到我每天都在做的
every day. But he doesn't have the luxury, like a newspaper writer who needs to write a column, you don't always have the luxury of having writers' block. So what he has done that I think is really interesting is he thinks of his creative ideas as though what he has is essentially a body of water and the clean, crystal clear water is at the bottom of this body, but on top of it sits a layer of muck. And the good ideas are covered by this muck. And the muck is, you know, I'm tired, I can't get motivated and it's the sort of sense of writer's block.
工作中。”但他没有奢侈，不像一个需要写专栏的报社作家，你并不总是拥有不会遇到作家阻滞的奢侈。所以他所做的事情，我认为非常有趣，他把自己的创造性想法看作是一个水体，干净、水晶般清澈的水在这个水体的底部，但在它上面坐落着一层污垢。好点子被这些污垢覆盖着。而污垢就是，“我很累，我无法获得动力”，这就是那种作家阻滞的感觉。
And he talks about pouring out the bad ideas metaphorically. And the way he does that is he'll sit at his computer or he'll sit with a pad and paper or he might sit at his keyboard or his guitar, you know, thinking about how he's going to write a song. And he'll say to himself, the best thing I can do right now if I don't want to be stuck is to act. It doesn't really matter what the action looks like, but I need to act because then, you know, by definition, I'm not stuck. And so what he does is he says, in those moments for, say, 10 or 15 minutes at the beginning of the day, I'm going to lower my usually very high threshold for what's acceptable to the ground and say anything is good, anything is acceptable for the purposes of getting the ball rolling.
他谈到隐喻性地倒掉不好的点子。他这样做的方法是，他会坐在电脑前，或者坐在带有纸笔的桌前，或者他可能会坐在键盘或吉他前（你知道的），思考他将如何写一首歌。他会对自己说：“我现在能做的最好的事情，如果我不想陷入困境的话，那就是行动。行动看起来是什么样的其实并不重要，但我需要行动，因为这样，（你知道的）根据定义，我就没有被困住。”所以他所做的是，他说，在那些时刻，比如一天开始的10到15分钟里，我要把通常很高的对于什么是可接受的标准降到地面，说任何东西都是好的，任何东西都是可接受的，只要能让事情滚动起来。
And so what he'll say to himself is something like, what's the worst musical phrase I could write right now? Or what's the worst passage that I could write? And the good news is if you've been doing this for long enough, it's very easy to do a bad job. But it turns out to be better than doing no job at all. And that's what he's found, that it really does seem to propel him forward. And then after he's done that for a bit, he gets into the groove. And so for him, there is essentially no writer's block once he uses that tactic. And that's how I often think of writer's block, that as long as you act,
所以他会对自己说这样的话：“我现在能写出的最糟糕的音乐短语是什么？或者我能写出的最糟糕的段落是什么？”好消息是，如果你做这件事足够久，要做好一件坏事是非常容易的。但事实证明，这总比什么都不做好。这就是他发现的，这确实似乎推动他向前发展。然后在他这样做了一会儿之后，他就进入状态了。所以对他来说，一旦他使用了这个战术，基本上就没有作家阻滞了。这就是我通常对作家阻滞的看法，只要你行动，
even if the action is sideways, you'll get overriders block. It seems like one reason people get stuck these days, especially when they're trying to make a decision, is because there's so much information available at our fingertips right now. You give the example in the book of trying to decide what kind of car to get. What advice do you have for people when they get analysis, paralysis, because there's too much information to sift through? I think it's tempting to think of ourselves as a particular kind of decision maker. You know, like often we see our decision making as a sort of expression of wisdom.
即使行动是歪打正着，你也能克服作家阻滞。似乎现在人们陷入困境的一个原因，特别是当他们试图做决定时，是因为我们指尖有太多的信息。你在书中举了决定买什么类型车的例子。当人们因为有太多信息需要筛选而陷入分析瘫痪时，你有什么建议？人们很容易认为自己是一种特定类型的决策者。你知道，通常我们将决策视为一种智慧的表达。
You know, I make good decisions. I'm a good decision maker. I make the right decision. I think a better way to think about decision making is to think of every decision in terms of its gravity. And to ask yourself, is this a case where I need to be absolutely right? I need to make the very best decision, which is known as maximizing. I maximize the outcome, or is this a case where I can, the alternative is satisfying, where I basically say there's a hurdle, I need to get over that hurdle, and as long as I come up
你知道，我做出了好决定。我是一个好的决策者。我做出了正确的决定。我认为看待决策的一个更好的方法是根据其重要性（gravity）来对待每一个决策。并问自己：这是一个我绝对需要正确的案例吗？我需要做出最好的决定，这被称为最大化。我将结果最大化，或者这是一个我可以通过满足（satisficing）来解决的案例，基本上我说有一个障碍，我需要克服那个障碍，只要我遇到一个
against an option that's good enough, that's acceptable here. I don't need to find the perfect option. So there may be some areas of your life, for example, picking a partner or deciding whether they have children or deciding which house to buy or which town to live in or country to live in. Those are big decisions, and I think they warrant a lot of care and attention. And so you should, you should feel to some extent paralyzed by that decision and you should take a long time making it. But if you're standing at a wall of sodas at the supermarket and you're spending four hours trying to decide whether to go between Coke and Pepsi, that's a good case for satisfying. And I think most decisions we make during the day, even if there are hundreds of them,
足够好、在这里可以接受的选择。我不需要找到完美的选项。所以你生活中的某些领域可能是这样的，例如挑选伴侣、决定是否要孩子、决定买哪栋房子、或者住在哪个城镇或国家。这些都是重大的决定，我认为它们值得投入大量的关怀和注意力。因此，在某种程度上，你应该对那个决定感到瘫痪，你应该花很长的时间去做出它。但如果你站在超市的苏打水货架前，花四个小时试图决定是在可乐还是百事可乐之间做出选择，这是一个很好的选择满意（satisficing）的例子。我认为我们白天做的大多数决定，即使有几百个，
99% of them probably fall in the satisfying camp. And there's a lot of research on satisfices versus maximizes, people who generally say good enough is good enough versus perfection is the only thing I'm looking for. If you hunt for perfection, you will be less happy, both with what you choose, but also in life in general. And so I think learning to distinguish these cases where it's essential to make the right decision from the ones where it doesn't actually matter that much is a really useful life philosophy. I hope that comes as a relief to some of our listeners.
其中99%可能都属于“满足（satisficing）”阵营。关于追求满足者与追求最大化者有很多研究，这些人通常说“足够好就是足够好”，而另一些人则认为“完美是我唯一的追求”。如果你寻找完美，你会不那么快乐，无论对你选择的东西还是对生活本身。因此，我认为学会区分那些必须做出正确决策的情况与那些实际上并不那么重要的决策，是一种非常有用的人生哲学。我希望这能给我们的听众带来一些解脱。
Yeah. Since artificial intelligence is all over the news today's, I'd want to ask you if you've given any thought to how AI might help us get unstuck. And I'm thinking about a conversation I had with a colleague just the other day who had a work assignment where he had to synthesize a bunch of information and come up with recommendations. He didn't have a lot of time. He didn't see any immediate answer. So he turned to chat GPT, poured in the source information, and it spit out what he needed. So do you think generative AI is going to be another answer to getting unstuck? Yes, very much so. Unfortunately, as an educator, I'm now stuck because half of the assignments I've assigned
是的。既然人工智能今天到处都是新闻，我想问你是否考虑过人工智能如何能帮我们摆脱困境。我想起我前几天和一位同事的对话，他有一项工作任务，必须综合大量信息并提出建议。他没有很多时间。他没有看到任何直接的答案。于是他转向了ChatGPT，把源信息倒进去，它就吐出了他需要的东西。所以你觉得生成式人工智能会成为摆脱困境的另一个答案吗？是的，非常如此。不幸的是，作为一名教育工作者，我现在陷入困境了，因为我过去20年布置的一半作业
for the last 20 years are no longer viable. But my situation aside, I think it's a tremendous resource. And I think where it does its best work is, you know, we talked a little bit earlier about this idea of consulting others who are a bit different from you for advice and when you feel stuck. And I think chat GPT functions as essentially the collected wisdom of millions of different agents that are out there in the world because it's combing what's available on the internet. So generative AI for me is this great unsticking force that can be used as the kind of first step in the process, whatever the process might be. So I think that's usually where we get stuck. It's going from zero to one.
已经不再适用了。但抛开我的处境不谈，我认为这是一项巨大的资源。我认为它发挥最佳作用的地方是，我们刚才讨论了“向与你有点不同的人寻求建议”的想法，当你感到困境时。我认为ChatGPT基本上可以作为世界上数百万不同智能体汇聚的智慧发挥作用，因为它在梳理互联网上可用的内容。所以对我来说，生成式人工智能是一种伟大的打破困境的力量，可以用作任何过程的第一步，无论这个过程可能是什么。所以我认为这通常是我们陷入困境的地方。它是从零到一的过程。
And an example of this is if I'm sitting and struggling to write the beginning sentence of a chapter or the beginning paragraph of a chapter and I'm writing a book, which is something I've done a few times now, and I've often been stuck at the beginning of a chapter, it's a difficult thing to do. One thing you can do, and I have done this with ChatGPT occasionally, is you can say to it, I'm writing a book chapter, this is what the chapter is about, you can give it a brief description. Tell me five different ways that you could write this chapter, you could begin the chapter. That doesn't mean you're plagiarizing, but what it's doing is it's getting you to think about some different options, the way you might, if you'd spoken to five of your best writer friends, and they said, well, here's what I would do. instantly, without having to check schedules and so on, you have this device or this platform that's telling you here are five different ways to do it. And the nice thing about chat GPT is if you say to it, you know, let's imagine that the last thing you said was wrong or let's improve on what you just did. It'll do that for you. And so you can push it and prod it in different directions.
一个例子是，如果我坐着，艰难地写一章的开头句子或开头段落，而我正在写一本书，这是我已经做过好几次的事情，而且我经常在章节的开始感到卡壳，这是一件困难的事情。你可以做的一件事（我偶尔也会用ChatGPT这样做）是你可以对它说：“我正在写一本书的一个章节，这是这一章的内容，”你可以给它一个简短的描述。“告诉我写这一章、可以开始这一章的五种不同方法。”这并不意味着你在抄袭，但它做的是让你思考一些不同的选项，就像如果你和你的五个最好的作家朋友交谈，他们说：“嗯，这就是我会做的。”瞬间，不需要核对日程安排等等，你就有这个设备或这个平台告诉你这里有五种不同的方法。而ChatGPT的好处是，如果你对它说：“你知道，让我们假设你刚才说的话是错的，或者让我们改进你刚才做的事情，”它会为你这样做。所以你可以从不同的方向推动和敦促它。
So I find it a tremendous brainstorming partner for that early phase where you feel stuck and where you're trying to move from, you know, zero miles an hour to maybe 10 miles an hour. From 10 to 60, if that's what your goal is, you might have to do that on your own, but it gets you started. Let's talk for a moment about the role of fear in being stuck. Do people sometimes get stuck just because they're afraid of change or of the unknown? Yeah, so this survey that I've been running on people around the world, one of the questions I ask is tell me what it feels like as you think about being stuck. and it's not surprising, I think, that the emotions they feel are negative.
所以我发现它是一个极好的头脑风暴伙伴，适用于你感到困境的早期阶段，以及你试图从每小时0英里移动到也许每小时10英里的阶段。从10到60，如果那是你的目标，你可能得靠自己完成，但它让你开始了。让我们花一点时间谈谈恐惧在陷入困境中的作用。人们有时会仅仅因为害怕改变或未知而陷入困境吗？是的，我在世界各地的人们中进行的这项调查中，我问的一个问题是：告诉当你想起被困住时的感觉是怎样的。
And fear comes up quite often. Anxiety comes up quite often. There's a real sense of isolation and loneliness, despite the fact that it seems near universal. It's often hidden from us that others are stuck as well. And I find one of the best ways to get over that fear of feeling stuck is to shine sunlight on this idea that being stuck is universal. And in fact, the beginning of the book, I spent quite a long time trying to
毫不奇怪，他们感受到的情绪是负面的。恐惧经常出现。焦虑经常出现。有一种真正的孤立感和孤独感，尽管这种感觉似乎几乎是普遍的。我们常常被隐藏了这样一个事实：其他人也被困住了。我发现克服对被困住的恐惧的最好方法之一，就是将阳光照耀在“被困住是普遍现象”这个观点上。事实上，在书的开头，我花了相当长的时间试图
figure out whether there were some classic examples of tremendously successful people from the outside who once you look at the process that was hidden from the world, you find, turns out they were very, very afraid, very stuck, very uncomfortable until they weren't. And you find this with some of the biggest businesses in the world. I talk about Amazon and Airbnb. You find it with some of the most successful artists. I specifically focus at the beginning of the book on Brie Larson, the actress who won an Academy Award for Best Actress. And, you know, I, I, I, I'm yet to find someone who says, in all honesty, I was never stuck. It was always easy. It was plain sailing. It was not an issue for me at all. And so, yes, going back to your question,
弄清楚是否有这样一些经典例子：表面上极其成功的人，一旦你看一下对世界隐藏的过程，你就会发现，原来他们也非常非常害怕，非常被困住，非常不舒服，直到他们不再如此。你在一些世界上最大的企业中也会发现这一点。我谈到了亚马逊和爱彼迎（Airbnb）。你在一些最成功的艺术家身上也能发现这一点。我特别在书的开头把重点放在了布丽·拉尔森（Brie Larson）身上，这位获得奥斯卡最佳女主角的女演员。而且，你知道，我，我，我，我还没有遇到过一个人坦诚地说：“我从来没有被困住过。一切总是那么容易。那是风平浪静的。对我来说根本不是问题。”所以，是的，回到你的问题。
I think fear is a very big factor that prevents people from moving forward. But so much of that comes from the sense that this is a sort of unique experience that I'm going through. And once you get past that, it usually feels, in my experience, quite liberating. And people do move forward. when a person's been stuck on something for a long time, how do they know when it's time to quit versus whether they should continue to try to push through? Is there some kind of a cost-benefit analysis that people could do in such cases? Yeah, it's a very interesting and important question. It's one of the big questions that comes up. In the book, I think I push quite firmly on the idea of persevering in general because I think a lot of the research suggests there's a lot of value
我认为恐惧是阻碍人们前进的一个非常大的因素。但其中很大一部分原因来自于一种感觉，即我正在经历的是一种独特的体验。一旦你跨过了这个坎，以我的经验来看，通常会觉得相当解放。人们也确实在向前迈进。当一个人被某件事卡住很久时，他们怎么知道什么时候该放弃，什么时候该继续坚持下去？在这种情况人们可以做某种成本效益分析吗？是的，这是一个非常有趣且重要的问题。这是经常出现的大问题之一。在这本书中，我认为我相当坚定地主张总的来说要坚持不懈，因为我认为很多研究表明，坚持下去有很大的价值
to persevering beyond the point where things get difficult. There are also some phenomenal books, including a book by Annie Duke called Quit, which is about the opposite. How do you know when to stop? And obviously, a wise assessment suggests that you can't always push forward and you can't always quit. You need to know how to distinguish the two. One of the useful pieces of advice that I've come across from people who seem to find
即坚持到事情变得困难的那个点之后。也有一些非常棒的书籍，包括安妮·杜克（Annie Duke）写的《放弃》（Quit），这本书讲的是相反的内容。你怎么知道什么时候该停下来？很显然，明智的评估表明，你不能总是硬着头皮前进，也不能总是说放弃就放弃。你需要知道如何区分这两者。我从那些似乎能很好地找到中间平衡点的人那里听到过一个很有用的建议
the middle ground quite well is they will describe a sense of convergence on a an endpoint that they desire. So if you're learning a language or a skill or you're trying to produce a creative idea or you have a business or you're trying out a career or you're trying a new major in college, whatever it might be, you'll probably run into some hardship. You can't quit at the first sign of hardship. That's what a lot of the research suggests. But if all you're doing is slogging through the process and you don't feel like you're converging on something promising, rewarding, that makes you feel good, that brings you the emotional returns you're looking for, then at some point you do need to quit.
他们会描述一种向他们渴望的终点收敛的感觉。因此，如果你在学习一门语言或一项技能，或者你正试图产生一个创意的想法，或者你拥有一家企业，或者你正在尝试一项职业，或者你在大学里尝试一个新的专业，无论它是什么，你都可能会遇到一些困难。你不能在遇到困难的第一迹象时就放弃。这就是许多研究所表明的。但如果你所做的只是艰难地熬过这个过程，而且你并不觉得自己在向某个充满希望、有回报、让你感觉良好、能带来你所寻找的情感回报的事情靠拢，那么在某个时刻，你确实需要放弃。
And so one of the things you can do, sometimes there's an objective standard that helps you do this, but one thing you can do is to ask, am I getting closer to the goal over time, am I converging? Is the gap between my current skill level or my experience now and where I'd like to be shrinking or is it staying the same size or is it even getting larger? And once it starts getting larger and you feel like you're getting further and further from where you want to be, I think you start to make a good, case for quitting. But I think the idea of quitting as an empty idea doesn't make much sense.
所以你能做的事情之一——有时有一个客观标准可以帮助你做到这一点——但你能做的一件事就是问：随着时间的推移，我离目标更近了吗？我是在收敛吗？我当前的技能水平或现在的体验与我想达到的目标之间的差距是在缩小，还是保持不变，甚至在变大？一旦这个差距开始变大，你觉得离你想去的地方越来越远，我认为这就为放弃提供了充分的理由。不过，我认为把放弃看作是一个空洞的概念是没有什么意义的。
For me, it's always, what are you quitting to? What happens next? And so in my experience, when I've moved through different processes and when I've decided not to do something, the best thing you can do is really to line up the next thing and wherever possible, especially if it's a professional or creative endeavor. Now, in addition to your academic work, you do a lot of consulting with companies. and organizations. I'm wondering if the advice you give them is similar to the advice that you give to individuals in terms of how to get unstuck.
对我来说，这总是：你放弃是为了转向什么？接下来会发生什么？因此，根据我的经验，当我经历不同的过程并决定不做某事时，你能做的最好的事情确实是把下一件事情安排好，无论什么时候都要尽可能做到，特别是当它是一项职业或创意事业时。现在，除了学术工作之外，你还为公司和组织提供大量的咨询。我想知道，你给他们的建议是否类似于你给个人的建议，也就是关于如何摆脱困境。
It's broadly similar. In the book, I focus on individuals to a large extent, but I also talk about organizations and management and marketing problems specifically. A lot of the ideas, I think, are leadership-oriented. How do you put together a team? How do you put together a brain trust so that you maximize the chance of an organization unsticking. So there are some ideas that I think are germane to business decision making, maybe more than everyday life. But I always find, you know, I think one of the big skills that
大体上是相似的。在书中，我在很大程度上关注个人，但我也专门讨论了组织、管理和营销方面的问题。我认为许多想法都是以领导力为导向的。你如何组建一个团队？你如何组建一个智囊团，以最大化地提高组织摆脱困境的几率？因此，有些想法我认为与商业决策息息相关，可能比日常生活更是如此。但我总是发现，你知道，我认为心理学家随着时间推移学到的重大技能之一就是
we psychologists learn over time is that useful ideas have a lot of applications. And the best thing you can do is try to figure out where they apply. And often they apply more broadly than your instincts might suggest. And so I think a lot of the ideas, even, so here's an example, if I'm putting together a team and I'm trying to work out what sort of employees to put on that team, another question that you might ask, the individual version of that might be, I'm trying to put together a group of trusted people that I can turn to when I feel like I don't know how to move forward. And it turns out the same rules about composing that team at the workplace and in life, in general, hold. And so I think you can learn a tremendous amount from the business ideas and also
有用的想法有很多应用。你能做的最好的事情就是试着找出它们在哪里适用。通常它们的适用范围比你的直觉所暗示的要广泛得多。因此，我认为许多想法——举个例子，如果我要组建一个团队，并且我正在努力弄清楚应该把什么样的员工放进这个团队里，你可能会问的另一个问题，其个人版本可能是：我正在努力组建一群值得信赖的人，当我觉得自己不知道该如何前进时，我可以向他们求助。事实证明，关于在职场中和生活中总体上组建该团队的规则是相同的。因此，我认为你可以从商业理念中学到极多，并且
the business ideas, I think, gain a lot from just what it is to be an, individual human being navigating the world. Is there any other advice that we haven't discussed that you'd want to leave with our listeners today? I think one thing I'll say is we, in childhood, I have a five-year-old and a seven-year-old, and in childhood there's a lot of curiosity. We find the world a curious place. We ask a huge number of questions.
我也认为商业理念从作为一个在世界上航行的普通个人中获益良多。我们今天还有什么没有讨论过的建议想留给我们的听众吗？我想说的一点是，我们在童年时期——我有一个五岁和一个七岁的孩子——童年时期有很强的好奇心。我们发现世界是一个充满好奇的地方。我们提出了大量的问题。
We're very rarely satisfied by the first, second or third answers we get. And so we push forward constantly and, you know, kids are never satisfied with the answers they get. At some point between being a child and being an adult that shifts, we start to assume that common wisdom is common wisdom for a reason. Adults don't question that much. You know, you see other people doing something. You assume it's the right way where a child might say, why is that? And it turns out there are some adults who are natural, I call them experimentalists. It's a sort of philosophy of questioning everything.
我们很少对得到的第一个、第二个或第三个答案感到满意。因此，我们不断地向前推进，你知道，孩子们对他们得到的答案永远不会满足。在从孩子成长为成年人的某个时间点，情况发生了转变，我们开始认为常识之所以成为常识是有原因的。成年人不会提出那么多质疑。你知道，你看到别人在做什么。你就会认为那是正确的方法，而一个孩子可能会问：“为什么会这样？”事实证明，有些成年人天生就是——我称他们为实验主义者。这是一种质疑一切的哲学。
and wondering whether with the right experiment there might be a better way. Is there a better way for me to communicate with my loved ones? Is there a better way for me to work in the workplace? Is there a better way for me even narrowly to learn how to play a particular piano piece or paint a particular painting? It doesn't really matter the task. But one of the chapters I talk about these people who are chronic experimentalists and how, for some of them, it unlocks tremendous potential.
并且想知道通过正确的实验是否会有更好的方法。我有没有更好的方法与我爱的人沟通？我在职场中工作有没有更好的方法？甚至在狭义上，我有没有更好的方法来学习弹奏一首特定的钢琴曲或画一幅特定的画？任务是什么并不重要。但在其中一章中，我谈到了这些被称为“慢性实验主义者”的人，以及对他们中的一些人来说，这如何释放出巨大的潜力。
I talk about an Olympic swimmer who learned to be an Olympic swimmer at that level of proficiency by essentially saying, hey, the way everyone else is swimming the backstroke is not the best way. He pioneered a completely new technique. And there are other people in other domains too. So I think that's a really valuable approach to the world that keeps us, A, young, and B, makes us open, or keeps us open to the potential to do better in general. And I think it's one of the best ways to prevent yourself from getting stuck in the first place
我讲到了一位奥运会游泳运动员，他通过基本上说“嘿，其他人游仰泳的方法并不是最好的方法”，从而以那种熟练程度学会成为了一名奥运会游泳运动员。他开创了一种全新的技术。其他领域也有这样的人。所以我认为这是一种对世界非常有价值的方法，它能让我们，A，保持年轻，B，让我们保持开放的心态，或者保持对普遍做得更好的潜力的开放态度。我认为这是防止自己一开始就陷入困境的最好方法之一
is to always say, oh yeah, this is starting to feel a little bit sticky. it's not working the way I'd like. I think I need to consider alternatives. And that's, I think, a very useful piece of advice. And what's next for you? What else are you working on besides stuckness? Yeah, so I'm constantly working on a whole lot of ideas. In fact, I talk about this in the book, that I have this document that's called
那就是随时对自己说：“哦，是的，这开始觉得有点卡壳了。它的运作方式不如我所愿。我想我需要考虑替代方案。”我认为这是一个非常实用的建议。接下来你有什么打算？除了摆脱困境，你还在研究什么？是的，我一直在研究一整套的想法。事实上，我在书里也谈到了这一点，我有一份文件叫做
research ideas and another document called book ideas. And what they essentially are is 20 years worth of interesting ideas that have either come to me that I've come across in the world, it would take me 100 lifetimes to actually pursue all of them. So at the moment, I'm very invested in the book and in the question of how we can get unstuck in lots of different contexts. But at some point, I'm sure I'll return to those documents and figure out what's next. Well, I want to thank you for joining me today, Dr. Alter. This has been really interesting.
研究想法，还有另一份文件叫做书的想法。它们本质上是长达20年的有趣想法，这些想法要么是我自己想到的，要么是我在世界上遇到的，我需要100辈子的时间才能真正把它们全部付诸实践。所以目前，我非常投入到这本书中，投入到我们如何在许多不同的情境中摆脱困境的问题中。但在某个时刻，我确信我会回到那些文件中去弄清楚接下来要做什么。嗯，非常感谢你今天能来，奥尔特博士。这真的非常有趣。
Thanks so much for having me. Kim, I really enjoyed it. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢邀请我。金，我真的很喜欢。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、Stitcher、YouTube 以及任何你获取喜爱的播客的平台上找到《心理学聊斋》（Speaking of Psychology）往期的节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请给我们留个评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，你可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。本节目由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·康迪安（Chris Condyenne）。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。